let us begin with the clearest picture
yet of what happened on january 6 as
laid out in a prime time public hearing
on capitol hill the event began slowly
with detailed statements from the chair
and vice chair of the committee but then
there was the video
almost 12 minutes of footage much of it
never seen before showing not just the
shocking violence of the crowd but also
the timing of the day's events the goal
remind americans of how atrocious that
day was
we can't show you all of it but here's
just some of what was shared
yeah just for awareness be advised
there's probably about 300 uh proud boys
pence is going to have to come through
for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
the doors barricade there's people
flooded there's always outside we have
no way out
don't waste themselves it's time to
evacuate so we can secure the members on
the other side
at the center of all of this according
to the committee was former president
trump they call his actions an attempted
coup
one they say he cheered as it was
unfolding scott mcfarlane is at the
capitol with a lot more details
including never before seen testimony
from
former president's daughter ivanka trump
scott good morning what are we learning
hey vlad the committee made the case
january 6th was not a spontaneous attack
that among other things groups of the
far right proud boys were here in the
morning before donald trump even spoke
at the white house to do reconnaissance
to look for vulnerabilities in weak
spots in the police line here at the
capitol that they then capitalized and
led the mob in
with newly released video the house
select committee investigating the
january's sixth attack on the capitol
laid out their findings for the first
time in public in a rare prime time
hearing thursday night some of the
capitol police officers who defended
congress and their families watched in
the room overcome with emotion as they
relived the deadly day
at that point i had blacked out but my
back of my head clipped
the concrete stairs behind me
one injured officer caroline edwards
described it as a war zone there were
officers on the ground
you know
they were bleeding they were throwing up
they were you know they had
i mean i saw friends with blood all over
their faces i was slipping in people's
blood donald trump the president of the
united states
spurred a mob of domestic enemies of the
constitution
to march down the capitol and subvert
american democracy the committee wasted
little time directing the blame at
former president trump january 6 was the
culmination of an attempted coup
president trump summoned the mob
assembled the mob and lit the flame of
this attack he was mentioned nearly 100
times in just the opening statements
the committee making the case former
president trump endorsed the hanging of
his own vice president for not stopping
the 2020 election certification and
aware of the rioters chance to hang mike
pence the president responded with this
sentiment quote
maybe our supporters have the right idea
earlier thursday trump's former
education secretary betsy devos publicly
acknowledged for the first time she
explored using the 25th amendment to
remove him from office after the attack
they knew that president donald trump
was too dangerous to be left alone the
committee says its series of hearings
this month will show trump knowingly
lied about fraud in the election in
video clips his former attorney general
william barr said he was emphatic with
trump about false voter fraud claims
which i told the president was bullsh a
newly released video showed ivanka
trump's interview how did that affect
your perspective about the election when
attorney general barr made that
statement
it affected my perspective
i respect attorney general barr
so i
accepted what he said was saying since
the attack five police officers who
protected the capital january 6 died
more than 820 people have been
criminally charged so far with two more
arrested thursday including a republican
candidate for governor in michigan who
allegedly stormed the capitol i'm
trained to
detain
you know a couple of subjects and and
handle you know handle a crowd but i'm
not combat trained
and
that day it was just
hours
of hand-to-hand combat
the second hearing is monday the
committee says it'll show trump's team
new claims of election fraud were false
house republicans have largely boycotted
this committee after also voting to
block an independent commission to
investigate january 6. then tony one
other note the chairman of the committee
says they will release
all the transcripts from all the
depositions they've conducted by the end
of the year
that video still has the power to shock
scott thank you very much